significant secondary explosions from
the targeted vehicle indicated the
presence of a substantial amount of
explosive
material
we are aware of reports of civilian
casualties and we take these reports
very seriously and we are continuing to
assess the situation we take
efforts take steps from the united
states to avoid civilian casualties in
every scenario and probably more than
almost any country in the world i can't
speak to or confirm
the numbers or cases of civilian
casualties in this case
she can't but the new york times is
reporting that ten civilians including
seven children were killed by a drone
strike and kabul
now the biden pentagon assures us that
this strike and others neutralized
isis-k terrorists who they of course
can't tell us anything about or identify
so what's going on here joining us now
is independent journalist glenn
greenwald
glenn um no one in the media seems too
concerned about what looks like to be
another
intelligence failure why is that
it's pretty bizarre i mean right from
the beginning there was a huge question
lurking at least for me which is
you know a month ago joe biden assured
everybody that there was very little
chance that the taliban would overrun
the afghan national security forces and
would take over the country of course
that's exactly what happened five weeks
after he gave that assurance which seems
to suggest that if they weren't lying
they know very little about what's
happening in this country we've been
occupying for 20 years and then suddenly
we're told that they were able with
pinpoint precision twice in a row
to identify the location of two
different isis-k
planners or plotters or commanders which
seems very inconsistent with the fact
that they seem to have no idea what's
going on in this country they wouldn't
give us the names of who these
supposedly important people were and
they just asserted that there were no
civilian casualties and unlike in the
trump years when all these media outlets
love to say trump says this with no
evidence trump falsely claims
all their skepticism evaporated
overnight and they just repeated the
fact that we got our target there were
no civilian casualties and there was
never any evidence for it and no
questioning of it at all
well the pentagon is just they're not
going to release the names the
identities of these these terrorists
uh and it doesn't look like we're going
to learn much more about it than we
already have watch
there'll probably be a time when we can
talk to you about the the names that's
not the time right now we are still
dealing with as we saw from last night's
rocket attacks very real ongoing threats
and
i think we're doing what we believe to
be the prudent thing with respect to the
release of information we're giving you
as much as we can
in as close to real time as we can but
we're not going to be able to give you
everything
glenn this is the new trick they say
well now is not the time now is not the
time to demand accountability now is not
the time to ask questions now's not the
time to give us any identities
but the fact is it's never a good time
look this is one of the most major
national security events obviously in
the last decade or two if not
in our lifetimes people have different
opinions about whether we should have
left or shouldn't how we should have
done it but we all have the right to
know
what actually is going on what happened
in afghanistan and remember the media
during the trump years made a big
flamboyant showing of the importance of
transparency the washington post
actually adopted a motto specifically
for the trump
era that read democracy dies in darkness
and so here's john kirby the pentagon
spokesperson telling you that you have
to believe them when they tell you that
they killed really important people
involved in these attacks but you can't
even know who these people are why not
why can't we know that
we're just at being asked to accept
their word on
blind faith and every time this happens
or where you know you go and you kill an
entire family just wipe them off the
face of the planet young children it
isn't that anybody questions whether or
not we had the right to do a retaliatory
strike after that hideous attack in
kabul of course we did but every time
that happens it generates so much
anti-american hatred and anti-american
sentiment around the world we need to
know at the very least whether it was
actually a legitimate strike or whether
it was just something that was done for
biden to get rid of a bad news cycle and
to prevent people from saying that he's
weak and the lack of interest on the
part of the media is amazing in that
well uh there's a lot of kids
there's a lot of kids
who are dead and i think we should know
whether a drone strike actually killed
them
uh it's basic question glenn thank you
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else